bonjour driss à cannes en bail merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
on l'a vu une mobilisation importante
hier après les sanctions de la cedeao
visant la jante malienne est ce que la
majorité des maliens dénoncé mesure où
la population est divisée
merci beaucoup
vous avez vu avec moi les images qui
parlent d'elle-même
donc en fait les maliens dans leur
grande majorité se sentent attaqués en
fait il il faut pas confondre la junte
au voilier aussi parce que la population
les conséquences de ces sanctions sont
directement ou indirectement de l'impact
sur la population c'est ce qui fait que
il ya vraiment même ceux qui étaient
modérées par rapport aux
nouvelles autorités de la transition se
sont ralliés à la cause pour défendre la
partie qu'elle considère être désormais
en danger
conséquence directe de ces sanctions de
la cedeao sur la population
vous savez déjà le mali est un embargo
en toi une bonne partie notamment du
centre et c est un embargo depuis
maintenant plus de cinq ans ou les
villages ont été brûlées des gens ont
étudié des femmes ont été violées de
vols ont été commis et c'est donc là la
conseil que le peuple est désormais et
résilients et dire que de toute façon on
ne peut pas il ne peut arriver de pire
que ce qui se passe depuis cinq ans donc
effectivement il faut pas quand même
s'il est vrai que c'est un pays
continental comme les mali
mais pas totalement il est très
difficile de s'en sortir comme ça quand
les frontières sont fermées parce qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup de produits
d'importation qui viennent par exemple
du sénégal et d'autres pays écoutiez
c'est pas facile mais c'est qui ce passe
en fait les maliens se sentent attaqués
dans leur dignité donc c'est plutôt un
combat de dignité qui est en train de de
ce fait le voir
mais pour en revenir à ces sanctions est
ce que la jante malienne elle va pouvoir
tenir finalement
libé c'est pas des télé je crois qu'elle
est le destin d'un peuple euh ouais ça
fait que souliers c'est vrai que les
maliens à souffrir mais je crois que les
pays voisins aussi comme le sénégal la
côte d'ivoire et c'est à souffrir en
cause aussi mais il faut pas quand même
c'est l'airé pour tout dire que le mali
est capable de tenir pendant une longue
période une telle sanction qui est
vraiment comme tout le monde elle est
connue tout à fait il lui même alors des
sanctions soutenue par l'europe qui
compte également sévir quelles nouvelles
sanctions européennes pourraient
s'ajouter à celle de la cedeao
moi j'y crois qu'il ya une sorte de
paranoïa et une hystérie collective où
tout le monde est désormais en train de
confondre la barbe et la cravate je
crois qu'il faut entre les châtiments
les mesures tout ce qui se passe il faut
de la pédagogie il faut de la
compréhension il faut de
l'accompagnement ce qui est un pays qui
est en guerre depuis 10 ans et que tout
le monde
s'accorde à sanctionner ces pays ce
n'est pas vraiment la junte au pouvoir
qui sera directement touchés à toi dans
un premier temps mais c'est la
population qui en souffrira donc moi je
crois qu'il faut beaucoup de pédagogie
au lieu de ces villes parce que quand
vous habitez quelqu'un même un enfant a
frappé je crois que c'est pas le bon
l'apprentissage est beaucoup mieux la
pédagogie l'accompagnement sont quand
même des valeurs plus sûres que les
châtiments donc l'union européenne
effectivement à 10 sur la la la cedeao
mais c'est qui est contradictoire parce
que quand on sait de certains pays sous
thème des despotes en afrique qui sont
nombreux vous le savez très bien et
maintenant on ne comprend pas cet
acharnement
on sent une sorte d'acharnement sur les
maliens alors qu'il ya des cas
similaires qui ont quand même été
beaucoup plus pardonné alors la france
en tête pour dénoncer la junte malienne
quelles pourraient être les conséquences
de cette défiance à l'égard de la france
notamment sur la lutte contre le
djihadisme la france toujours présentes
sur place avec l'opération au barca dans
leur appel
bon y'a aucune défiance contre qui que
ce soit en fait où
on fait face à un public et éprouvée qui
a fatigué qui cessa signer depuis plus
de dix ans c'est vrai que la france
accompagné les maliens continuent
d'accompagner comme les autres pays de
l'union européenne l'onu etc mais la
réalité est qu'il n'ya pas des résultats
parce que les résultats c'est toujours
des morts c'est tous des villages
incendiés c'est toujours des populations
déplacées donc les gens ne comprennent
pas comment est-ce que avec tout cet
appel qui a plu à environ trente mille
soldats sur le sol malien depuis
maintenant près de dix ans et que les
résultats ne sont pas là donc finalement
en désespoir de cause les maliennes et
les autorités essayent de trouver
d'autres alliés qui pourrait
éventuellement les aider à juguler en
quelque sorte le terrorisme généralisée
désormais des alliés qui pourrait être
la russie et la chine par exemple
moi je crois que les gens sont prêts
aujourd'hui à salies et même les gaps
même avec le diable s'il le faut pourvu
qu'ils aient un résultat vraiment
arrêter cette hémorragie qui n'a que
trop duré c'est ça les problèmes les
problèmes n'est pas et choisir un tel
pour un autre prendre jean paul non les
la stratégie c'est de trouver des alliés
des personnes ou je ne sais pas qui que
ce soit qui pourrait vraiment
éventuellement nous aider à juguler
comme j'ai dit l'été russie donc ça
c'est ce que j'ai vu mais
à la longue l'idée c'est vraiment arrivé
à professionnaliser l'armée malienne et
comptez sur nous parce que quoi qu'on
dise lundi qu'il ne nous permet pas de
nous en passer de l'aisne est totalement
inutile
pour conclure en quelques mots ça veut
dire que pour les maliens la france a
échoué dans sa mission au mali
mais ça
c'est très clair c'est pas pour les
maliens seulement les chiffres c'est le
chiffre qui parle il faut pas dire qu'il
faut pas insulter n'ont plus la main qui
nous nourrit il faut il reconnaître
quand même la france dans tous ces cas
là qu'elle a fait et c mais il faut
quand même se mettre à l'évidence que
les résultats ne sont pas là parce que
quand la france intervenait avec
l'opération serval en janvier 2012 vous
avez vu comment est ce que le président
konan a été hacké remercié par les par
les maliens parce que le mali n'est pas
un peuple ingrat mais maintenant on a
quand même on assiste à d'autres
malgré les petits la population ne
comprend pas voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui
on pense que en plus de la france de
l'union européenne etc il faut aussi
d'autres alliés qui peuvent nous aider
dans d'autres domaines puisque il ya eu
quand même je vous rappelle il met les
configurations de berkane qui a quand
même
quitté les bases de kidal de tessalit et
de tombouctou donc la nature ayant
horreur du vide on essaie de combler
ceux qui restent merci beaucoup drissa
requins en bail d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes président du
collectif malien en belgique